احتاج الامر الى يومين حتى تفرج الولايات
المتحده عم تعتبره قرينه تقطع الشك
باليقين ازاء ملابسات الحادث الجوي فوق
البحر الاسود بالنسبه للبنتاغون فان هذا
الفيديو الذي وثقته كاميرا المسيره
الامريكيه يظهر اعتراضا غير امن في المجال
الجوي الدولي ويؤكد بالتالي روايه واشنطن
لا نعلم بعد ما اذا كان الاسقاط متعمدا ام
لا لكننا نعلم ان الاعتراض كان متعمدا كما
ان السلوك العدواني مقصود وكان غير مهني
وغير امن لدينا دليل مصور على الاعتراض
الذي كان عدوانيا للغايه كما تم القاء
الوقود على المسيره ولست متاكدا من احتكاك
الطائره بها من الواضح اننا لا نسعى الى
صراع مسلح مع روسيا روسيا ايضا لا تبدو
راغبه في اي مواجهه تقول المتحدثه باسم
خارجيتها
من المهم ابقاء قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه وهي
كذلك نحن لا نسعى الى المواجهه وندعم
التعاون البراغماتي الذي يصب في مصالح
الشعوب بلدين علما اننا نجيد حمايه هذه
المصالح بين ان تلك التطمينات المتبادله
لا تعني باي حال التزامه واشنطن وموسكو
باعاده النظر في ترتيباتهما العسكريه
والامنيه لئلا يتكرر الحادث
منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي اكد
استمرار واشنطن في استخدام المسيرات فوق
البحر الاسود لضمان مصالحها ولتمكين
اوكرانيا من الدفاع عن نفسها على حد قوله
قبل ذلك ابلغ وزير الدفاع الروسي نظيره
الامريكي ان اطلعات الجويه قباله سواحل
القرم استفزازيه وان موسكو سترد على تلك
الاستفزازات
تنصب جهود الامريكيين الان على محاوله
اثبات تطابق الوقائع مع النوايا الروسيه
ضد المسيره العسكريه فقد نقلت محطه ام بي
سي عن مسؤولين في اداره بايدن مطلعين على
تقارير استخباريه قولهم ان اعلى المستويات
في الكرملين اجازت ما وصفته بالتصرف
العدائي ضد المسيره فوق البحر الاسود لكن
لا تاكيد بان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين هو من امر بذلك شخصيا
اما جسم الطائره المسيره الغارق في اعماق
البحر الاسود فلا يبدو ذا اهميه للطرفين
حتى الان على الاقل مع ان اي تحقيق احادي
او مشترك يستوجب ضروره فحسب بقايا المسيره
لاماطه اللثام عن الحيثيات والملابسات